THIS MORNING AT TEN ABILITY AND
AN ADMINISTRATIVE REVIEW
COMMITTEE MEETING.
I'M.
GO AHEAD AND GET STARTED I WE DO
NOT HAVE A QUORUM BUT WE'LL GO
AHEAD AND START AS A SUB
COMMITTEE.
I YOU'VE GOT AUTHORS PRESENT
READY TO ADD READY TO PRESENT
[inaudible]
MR BLOOM.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR.
AND MEMBER -- I MET HERE TO
PRESENT -- A. B. SIX FIFTY THREE
WHICH WILL AUTHORIZE THE
DIRECTOR GENERAL SERVICES TO
ENTER INTO A LEASE AGREEMENT
WITH THE COUNTY OF LA FOR ONE
POINT THREE ACRES OF THE WEST
LOS ANGELES NATIONAL GUARD
ARMORY SAY.
THE COUNTY OF LA UNDER THE STATE
LEADERSHIP SUPERVISOR SHEILA
KEWL HAS OVER THE LAST YEAR AND
A HALF BEEN WORKING.
WITH RELEVANT CITY STATE AND
FEDERAL PARTNERS AND MY OFFICE
TO DISCUSS THE FEASIBILITY OF
BUILDING BRIDGE HOUSING SITE ON
THIS PROPERTY.
THE WEST LOS ANGELES ARMORY IS
SITUATED WITHIN SERVICE PLANNING
AREA FIVE FOUR SPOT FIVE AS WE
CALL IT IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY.
COVERING MOST OF THE WEST SIDE
AND IT SPANS SOME OF THE AS YOU
AS YOU CAN IMAGINE SOME OF THE
HIGHEST PROPERTY VALUE AND ALL
OF CALIFORNIA.
IT'S BEEN NEARLY IMPOSSIBLE TO
SAY INTERIM HOUSING FOR PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS TO THE
OUTRAGEOUS COST OF LAND IN OUR
ALREADY DANCE REGION.
AND SO THIS PROJECT -- WOULD BE
A IT'S REALLY HARD TO A IMAGINE
THIS THIS WOULD BE THE FIRST
BRIDGE HOUSING SITE FOR HOMELESS
INDIVIDUALS AND SPA. FIVE IN
OVER TWENTY YEARS THAT -- SPANS
THE ENTIRE PERIOD OF TIME THAT
I'VE BEEN AN ELECTIVE OFFICE --
AND I'VE BEEN WORKING ON
HOMELESSNESS AS AN ISSUE FOR ALL
OF THOSE YEARS SO FOR ME -- THIS
JUST A REMARKABLE STATISTIC WITH
BUILT OUT A FAIR AMOUNT OF OF
PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING AND
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN THE AREA
BUT BRIDGE HOUSING IS A PLACE
WHERE -- WE'VE REALLY FALLEN
BEHIND.
THE S. SPECIFIC TO THE PROJECT
ARE BEING DEVELOPED WITH THE
COUNTY ARCHITECT AS THE NATIONAL
GUARD.
AND DESIGN SHOULD BE COMPLETED
OVER THE NEXT FEW MONTHS.
CONCEPTUAL DRAWINGS HAVE BEEN
CREATED IN THE INTERIM IN AN
EFFORT TO BE TRANSPARENT WITH
THE COMMUNITY AND SO THAT --
DISCUSSIONS SUCK A CAN PROCEED
WITH THE COMMUNITIES THAT
SURROUND THE PROPERTY.
THE PROJECT WILL ALSO INCLUDE A
PARKING REPLACEMENT -- THEY'LL
BE A PARKING STRUCTURE WHERE THE
SURFACE LOT ALREADY EXISTS -- TO
ASSIST THE NATIONAL GUARD IN
ALLEVIATING THEIR OWN -- A
PARKING ISSUES.
AND ALL PARTIES AGREE THAT THIS
PROJECT WILL BE A MAJOR
ENHANCEMENT TO THE SITE.
THE COMMUNITY SURROUNDING THE
PROPERTY ARE VERY SUPPORTIVE AND
I'VE INTRODUCED THIS BILL SO
THAT WHEN THE DESIGN IS COMPLETE
AGREED UPON WE'LL BE ABLE TO
BREAK GROUND THROUGH THE
EXECUTION OF THIS LEASE.
AND TO GET THOSE -- GET GET
THESE OF FACILITIES ONLINE AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE -- WITH ME
TODAY ARE STEPHANIE COHEN A WHO
IS -- WITH SUPERVISOR SHEILA
KILLS OFFICE AND FORMERLY OF OF
OF ONE OF YOUR COLLEAGUES
OFFICES SHE'S VERY WELL TRAINED --
AND BROOKS LESSER WITH THIS --
THE PEOPLE CONCERNED ONE OF THE
PREMIER ALMOST SERVICE PROVIDERS
ON THE WEST SIDE.
OF WILL BE PROVIDING TESTIMONY.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND MEMBERS
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLOOM --
FOR HAVING US HERE TODAY AND FOR
INTRODUCING AB.
SIX FIVE THREE AS MR BLOOM
MENTIONED SUPERVISOR KILLS
OFFICE STARTED DISCUSSION ON
THIS PROJECT ALMOST TWO YEARS
AGO. TO EXPLORE OPTIONS TO
ALLEVIATE A SERIOUS SHELTER
CRISIS IN SERVICE PLANNING AREA.
FIVE THE LOS ANGELES HOMELESS
SERVICES AUTHORITIES TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN POINT IN TIME
CAL.
FOUND THAT THERE ARE THREE
THOUSAND FOUR HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
INDIVIDUALS ON SHELTERED IN
SERVICE AREA.
FIVE AND ONLY FIFTEEN BEDS FOR
INDIVIDUALS WITH NO SPECIALIZED
CATEGORY SUCH AS VETERAN
TRANSISTOR NEEDS TO YOUTH AND
FAMILIES.
THIS IS A STRIKINGLY LOW NUMBER
IN COMPARISON TO THE SERVICE
AREAS THAT BORDER FIVE FOR
EXAMPLE.
IN SERVICE AREA FOR WE HAVE
ALMOST EIGHT HUNDRED BADS AND IN
SERVICE SERVICE AREA TO THE SAN
FERNANDO VALLEY WE HAVE FOUR
HUNDRED BEDS.
IT OF THE COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES
HAS BEEN UTILIZING THE WEST LA
ARMORY MULTI PURPOSE ROOM INSIDE
OF THE BUILDING -- FOR OVER
FIFTEEN YEARS TO HOUSE THE
WINTER SHELTER PROGRAM A NIGHTLY
PROGRAM SERVING ONE HUNDRED AND
SIXTY INDIVIDUALS DURING THE
COLDER MONTHS OF NOVEMBER TO
MARCH.
WELL THE GOAL IS ALWAYS TO GIVE
INDIVIDUALS A WARM PLACE TO
SLEEP THE OUTCOMES FROM WINTER
SHELTER MODELS ARE VERY MODEST.
IN APRIL TWENTY SEVENTEEN THE
LOS ANGELES COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS MOVE TO EXAMINE ALL
WINTER SHELTERS IN THE COUNTY TO
DETERMINE.
IF THEY COULD BETTER SERVE THE
GROWING HOMELESS POPULATION BY
BECOMING YOUR AROUND TWENTY FOUR
SEVEN BRIDGE HOUSING THAT
INCLUDES INTENSIVE CASE
MANAGEMENT SERVICES. TWENTY FOUR
SEVEN BRIDGE HOUSING MODELS HAVE
DRAMATICALLY HIGHER RATES OF
PLACING CLIENTS IN PERMANENT
HOUSING AND IN THEIR
HOMELESSNESS.
AS SUCH AS MISTER BILLY MENTION
WE WORKED IN COLLABORATION WITH
THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES STATE
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS BLOOMING
KAMLAGER-DOVE.
AND OUR FEDERAL PARTNERS US
SENATORS FEINSTEIN AND HARRIS
AND CONGRESSMAN WILL TO COME TO
AN AGREEMENT WITH THE NATIONAL
GUARD TO MOVE FORWARD WITH
DESIGNING A PROJECT FOR REVIEW.
I BROUGHT THIS BOARD HERE JUST
TO SHOW YOU WHAT THE PROPERTY
LOOKS LIKE AND TO LET YOU KNOW --
WHERE ON THE PROPERTY WERE
PROPOSING TO BUILD?
SO IT WOULD BE THE TOP LEFT
CORNER WHICH IS THE NORTHEAST
CORNER OF THE PROPERTY.
AND SO THE CURRENT PROPOSALS TO
BUILD A NEW STRUCTURE IN THE
NORTHEAST CORNER OF THE PROPERTY
WITH A SEPARATE SEPARATE ENTRY
ACCESS WAY FROM THE ROAD -- THIS
WOULD ALLOW THE STRUCTURE AND
THE NATIONAL GUARD OPERATIONS TO
BE COMPLETELY SEPARATED.
THIS FACILITY WOULD SERVE
INDIVIDUAL MEN AND WOMEN ON
DIFFERENT FLOORS AND WE'RE
STARTING IN NUMBER OF ONE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY BEDS FOR
HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS FOR NOW.
ONE HUNDRED AND FIFTY AS AN
INDUSTRY STANDARD SIZE FOR WELL
MANAGED AND FINANCIALLY COST
EFFECTIVE BRIDGE HOUSING.
THE SERVICE PROVIDER FOR THIS
PROJECT HAS NOT YET BEEN
SELECTED BUT THE LOS ANGELES
HOMELESS SERVICES AUTHORITY HAS
A LIST OF APPROVED OPERATORS
THAT WE MAY SELECT FROM. ONE OF
THESE APPROVED OPERATORS.
AND IN ALREADY INCREDIBLE
OPERATOR IN SERVICE PLANNING
AREA FIVE AND SERVICE PLANNING
AREA FOR IS THE PEOPLE CONCERNED.
THE PEOPLE CONCERNED PROVIDES A
WIDE ARRAY OF INTENSIVE CASE
MANAGEMENT SERVICES PERMANENT
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING PROGRAMS
MENTAL HEALTH.
ACCESS CENTERS AND HAVE YEARS OF
EXPERIENCE MANAGING BURRS BRIDGE
HOUSING LOCATIONS.
WITH US TODAY ALSO IS -- BROOKS
LESSER CHIEF.
PROGRAMS OFFICER WITH THE PEOPLE
CONCERNED AND IT'S TO CHILL
SHALL SPEAK TO BRIDGE HOUSING
MANAGEMENT PROGRAM AND AND HOW
THIS CAN BE AN EFFECTIVE WAY IN
GETTING FOLKS REHABILITATING
TRANSITIONED INTO PERMANENT
SOLUTIONS.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME MEMBERS
I LOOK FORWARD TO ADDRESSING
YOUR QUESTIONS AFTER BROOKS
COMMENTS.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND MEMBERS
THANK YOU TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BLOOM FOR PRESENTING AB -- SIX
FIVE THREE STAFFING A PROJECT TO
LIKE THIS KIND OF BRIDGE HOUSING
PROJECT IS CRITICALLY IMPORTANT
TO MEET BOTH THE SHORT TERM
CRISIS NEEDS OF THE RESIDENTS.
AND THE LONG TERM GOAL OF
COMMUNITY REINTEGRATION WHILE
MAINTAINING THE FOCUS ON SAFETY
AND WELLNESS.
A MULTI DISCIPLINARY TEAM OF
CASE MANAGERS AND MENTAL HEALTH
PROVIDERS ARE ABLE TO ASSIST TO
ASSESS FOR UNMET NEEDS OF
PARTICIPANTS AND EITHER A
DRESSER MANAGE.
THESE NEEDS OR MAKE APPROPRIATE
LINKAGES WHETHER IT BE FOR
MEDICAL CARE SUBSTANCE USE
TREATMENTS OR SAYS FOR OTHER
BARRIERS TO NAVIGATING THROUGH
THE HOUSING PROCESS.
HOUSING NAVIGATORS SERVER
CRITICAL ROLE IN WALKING
PARTICIPANTS TO THE PERMANENT
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING PROCESS FROM
START TO FINISH.
FROM GATHERING NECESSARY
DOCUMENTS TO APPLY FOR HOUSING
OPTIONS THROUGH THE HOUSING
SEARCH AND FINALLY THROUGH THE
LEASE SIGNING PROCESS.
AS ONE COULD IMAGINE THIS CAN BE
AN INCREDIBLY CHALLENGING AND
TRIGGERING JOURNEY AND SO HAVING
A SERVICE PROVIDER TO ASSIST TO
ASSIST WITH ADDRESSING THESE
BARRIERS THE MOMENT THEY ARISE
IS CRITICAL.
NECESSARY SERVICES INCLUDE
INDIVIDUAL CASE MANAGEMENT TO
WORK TOWARDS THE CONCRETE GOALS
OF SECURING PERMANENT HOUSING
SKILL BUILDING GROUPS TO ASSIST
PARTICIPANTS WITH DEVELOPING THE
NECESSARY BUILDING BLOCKS TO
BEING A GOOD TENANT.
AND A GOOD NEIGHBOR AN
INDIVIDUAL AND GROUP COUNSELING
TO ADDRESS THE BROADER ISSUES
THAT IMPACT AN INDIVIDUAL'S
ABILITY TO FULLY RECOVER FROM
HOMELESSNESS.
AS A RESULT OF HOW IN DEPTH THIS
WORK CAN BE AND HOW LENGTHY THE
HOUSING PROCESS CAN BE AS WELL
IT IS IMPORTANT THAT SERVICE
PROVIDERS.
BE ABLE TO WORK WITH BRIDGE
HOUSING RESIDENTS BE ON THEIR
EXIT FROM THE HOUSING UNTIL THEY
FULLY INTEGRATED INTO THEIR NEW
COMMUNITY. FOR SOME THIS IS A
SIMPLE AND AS QUICK AS THE LEAST
SIGNING PROCESS WHILE FOR OTHERS
WITH MORE COMPLEX HISTORIES.
THIS CAN BE A MORE CHALLENGING
AND LENGTHY PROCESS.
FROM A LOGISTICAL STANDPOINT IN
ORDER TO AGE TO ENSURE WE ARE AT
HEARING TO BASS DRUM INFORMED
PRACTICES.
INDIVIDUAL SPACES DESIGNATED FOR
RESIDENTS AND BRIDGE HOUSING
THAT RESEMBLES SOMEWHAT OF A
CUBICLE.
THIS ALLOWS FOR A SENSE OF
PRIVACY INVEST SAFETY BOTH ON
THE PART OF THE RESIDENTS IN THE
STAFF WITH SOME LEVEL OF
VISIBILITY INTO THE SPACE WHICH
HOUSES AN INDIVIDUAL BAD AND
PRIVATE STORAGE AREA.
THE GOAL OF BRIDGE HOUSING IS TO
ENSURE THAT BOTH COMMUNITIES AND
IT'S INDIVIDUAL COMMUNITY
MEMBERS ARE SAFE AND WORKING
TOWARDS THE GOAL OF PERMANENT
HOUSING WELL RESIDENTS ARE IN
BRIDGE HOUSING THEY'RE WORKING
WITH THIS TEAM OF SKILLED
PROFESSIONALS.
WHO CAN SUPPORT THEM IN MEETING
THESE GOALS IN THE COMMUNITY IN
WHICH THEY FEEL AT HOME?
THE PEOPLE CONCERNS NEWEST
BRIDGE HOUSING FACILITY IS
CALLED A PLAN TODAY AND IT
TEMPORARILY HOUSES FORTY FIVE
INDIVIDUALS WHO WERE HOMELESS
JUST OUTSIDE OF THE UNION
STATION IN DOWNTOWN LA.
APPOINT A OPEN THIS PAST FALL
INTO SUCCESSFULLY WORKED WITH
I'M JUST UNDER 20%.
SUCCESSFULLY WORKED WITH HOUSING
I'M JUST UNDER 20% OF THE
RESIDENTS SO FAR IN A PERMANENT
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING.
AND PART OF WHAT IS CONTRIBUTED
TO THE SUCCESS HAS BEEN A
COLLABORATION BETWEEN LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND LOCAL --
MERCHANTS AND VENDORS WHO -- WHO
IS COMMON GOAL IS PERMANENT
HOUSING FOR THESE INDIVIDUALS --
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT THESE --
THESE RESIDENTS FORM BONDS WITH
THIS PROFESSIONAL SKILLED TEAM
OF A SERVICE PROVIDERS WHO CAN
ASSIST THEM IN INTEGRATING INTO
THEIR NEW COMMUNITY -- WHILE
ADDRESSING ANY BARRIERS THAT
ARISE THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME THIS MORNING.
THANK YOU AT THE FOR WE CONTINUE
TESTIMONY I WE'RE WE'RE JUST
GONNA PAS TO ESTABLISH QUORUM.
SECRETARY CAN YOU CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE [inaudible]
PETRIE-NORRIS PRESENT PT
PETRIE-NORRIS PRESENT PATTERSON.
BURKE.
BURKE PRESENT LACKEY.
LACKEY PRESENT MEDINA.
DINA PRESENT QUIRK SILVA.
SMITH.
SMITH PRESENT.
THANK YOU.
I ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
SORRY ABOUT THAT FILL THE
ISRAELI SHAUN BEHALF OF THE CITY
OF SANTA MONICA WOULD LIKE TO
THINK ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLOOM FOR
WORKING ON THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE.
AND WE ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT
THANKS.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SCENE NINE I QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
I DO HAVE JUST ONE QUICK
QUESTION AND THIS CERTAINLY
ENJOYS I DO PASS RECOMMENDATION
FROM THE FROM THIS COMMITTEE.
IF YOU COULD JUST BRIEFLY TOUCH
ON YOU MENTIONED THAT YOU HAD
GOOD COMMUNITY SUPPORT.
IF YOU COULD JUST YOU KNOW TAKE
A COUPLE MINUTES TO TOUCH ON HOW
YOU BUILT THAT SUPPORT JUST
BECAUSE I THINK IT IT COULD BE
INSTRUCTIVE AND USEFUL.
FOR SMITH.
IN HIS MOTHER SURE
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS LOOKING TO DO
SOME SIMILAR WORK IT'S IT'S
ACTUALLY SOMETHING THAT HAS BEEN
BUILT OVER TIME I THINK THE
CREDIBILITY OF THE SERVICE
PROVIDERS IS A LARGE PART OF IT.
MEETING WITH COMMUNITY MEMBERS
ON A REGULAR BASIS ADDRESSING
THE OF REALISTIC CONCERNS AND
PROBLEMS OF OF COMMUNITY MEMBERS
IT'S REALLY AN ONGOING PROCESS --
WE HAVE AT THE ARMORY PARTNERS
SO ALREADY WHO WERE IN PLACE
BECAUSE THERE'S A WINTER SHELTER
PROGRAM THAT OPERATES THERE AND
SAID THIS IS A COMMUNITY THAT IS
ALREADY ENGAGED ON THE ISSUE AND
SO I THINK THE NEXT STEPS ARE --
GOING TO BE TO ROLL OUT THIS
PROPOSAL AND MORE ROBUST FASHION
AND ENGAGE THE COMMUNITY.
TO FIND OUT WHAT THE SPECIFIC
CONCERNS ARE BECAUSE IN MY
EXPERIENCE WHEN YOU HAVE A UGH
UGH A REAL CONVERSATION -- AND
UNDERSTAND AND ARE ABLE TO
SEPARATE THE YOU KNOW JUST SORT
OF SOMETIMES THE WHAT COMES TO
THE FOR OUR THAT NIMBY ISSUES
PEOPLE GET ANGRY IF YOU CAN
SEPARATE THOSE ISSUES FROM THE
VERY REAL CONCERNS THAT PEOPLE
MAY HAVE ABOUT.
OF SECURITY IN A PARTICULAR
CORNER OF THE PROPERTY AND IS
THERE GOING TO BE TWENTY FOUR
HOUR SECURITY WHERE THEY YOU
KNOW HOW IS THAT GOING TO WORK.
THESE ARE QUESTIONS THAT -- CAN
ALL BE ANSWERED -- BUT THE
ANSWERS ARE ONLY GOOD IF IT'S
DONE THROUGH -- A GOOD
COMMUNICATION.
THANK YOU WE HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND I ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FOR MOVE ON MR BLOOM
WHICH LIKE TO CLOSE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME THANK
YOU.
SECRETARY IF YOU CAN PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
VETERAN AFFAIRS PETRIE-NORRIS.
THREE NORRIS I PATTERSON
[inaudible]
BURKE.
BURKE I LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE MEDINA MEDINA AYE
QUIRK SILVA.
SMITH.
SMITH HI.
AT WE IT WILL HOLD THAT THE A
ROLL OPEN TED LET OTHER MEMBERS
AT ON THE EXAMINING MATCH.
OKAY MOVING ON TO THANKS TO HAVE
FED WITH ANY OTHER.
AUTHOR SO WE'LL GO AHEAD AND
MOVE ON TO FILE ITEM.
EIGHT I AB ONE FOUR THREE ZERO
IT'S BURKE
.
THIS SPRING THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS I'M HERE TODAY TO
PRESENT AB FOURTEEN THIRTY A
BILL THE CITY COST EFFECTIVENESS
THAT IS JOINTLY AUTHORED WITH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER EDUARDO GARCIA.
CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN COMMITTED TO
REVERSING THE IMPACTS OF CLIMATE
CHANGE SINCE TWO THOUSAND SIX
WITH THE PASSAGE OF THE
CALIFORNIA GLOBAL WARMING
SOLUTIONS ACT.
EFFORTS BY THE STATE TO COMBAT
CLIMATE CHANGE INCLUDE
CALIFORNIA'S CRIME INVESTMENTS
RENEWABLE PORTFOLIO STANDARD AND
LOW CARBON FUEL STANDARD TO NAME
A FEW.
ASSEMBLY BILL FOURTEEN THIRTY
WOULD DIRECT STATE AGENCIES
INVOLVED WITH IMPLEMENTING THESE
PROGRAMS. TO DO SAM AND HOW THEY
DEFINED HER THE TERM COST
EFFECTIVE TO ENSURE THAT THE
STATE CAPITALIZE ON
OPPORTUNITIES TO VEST AND GOOD
JOBS AIR QUALITY IMPROVEMENT AND
JUST TRANSITION AND OTHER
BENEFITS FOR THE STATE.
BANK WHAT CONSTITUTES A COST
EFFECTIVE POLICY AND THE
CONCEPTS OF CALIFORNIANS CLIMATE
PROGRAMS THE SKATE STATE CAN
WORK TO MAXIMIZE PUBLIC DOLLARS
TO ENSURE THE BEST RETURN FOR
CALIFORNIANS INVESTMENTS.
AB FOURTEEN THIRTY REFLECTS
EXTENSIVE STAKEHOLDER ENGAGEMENT
WITH AGENCIES ON THIS VERY
QUESTION AND RIGHTS CLEAR
FOR THOSE ENGAGED ON THIS ISSUE --
WITH THAT I HAVE A CRT IS HERE
FROM THE BILLING.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIRMAN RECESS
IDEAS ON BEHALF OF THE STATE
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES
COUNCIL I APOLOGIZE FOR NOT
HAVING A SUPPORT LETTER IN THE
FILE FOR THIS BILL BUT WE DO --
CARE DEEPLY ABOUT -- THIS
PARTICULAR STUDY AND WHAT IT'S
TRYING TO MEASURE.
NOT ONLY BECAUSE OUR MEMBERS AND
THEIR FAMILIES ARE CONSUMERS ARE
IMPACTED BY THE IMPORTANT
LANDMARK POLICIES AT THE STATE
AND HAS ADOPTED IN HIS
EMPLOYMENT AND BUT ALSO BECAUSE
OUR MEMBERS ARE AT THE FOREFRONT
OF ALSO WORKING. TO ACHIEVE
THOSE LANDMARK POLICIES AND THE
R. P. S. IN ENERGY EFFICIENCY IN
THE GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION
FUNDS.
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
STATE HAS ENOUGH DATA TO STUDY
THE A COST EFFECTIVENESS IN THE
IMPACT NOT ONLY AND JOB CREATION
AND QUALITY JOB CREATION BUT
ALSO ON THE IMPACT OF WORKING
FAMILIES THAT THESE OF POLICIES
MAY HAVE FOR THOSE REASONS WE
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
AT ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
SCENE NINE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
SEE NINE QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
QUESTION.
I STEPPED OUT AND I DON'T SEE
MISS BURKE ON MY LIST SO I DON'T
KNOW AFTER WITH BILLS I WAS HI
THIS IS AB ONE FOUR THREE ZERO
WHICH IS.
JOINTLY AUTHORED WITH MR GARCIA
HOW THE GARCIA.
RIGHT I WITH A MOTION AND A
SECOND AND EITHER MISSION IS TO
PASS OUR SECRETARY LEE PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS PETRIE-NORRIS.
HI PETRIE-NORRIS I PATTERSON.
BURKE HI BURKE I LACKEY.
LACKEY I'M MEDINA.
MEDINA AYE QUIRK SILVA SMITH.
SMITH HI.
GREAT APP BELL IS OUT WILL HOLD
THE ROLE OF PENTEL OUR OTHER
MEMBERS TO ADD ON MOVING ON I
THINK. TWENTY TRY TO TRACK DOWN
SETMA SOME AUTHORS.
CáC.
WATER WAITING LET'S GO AHEAD AND
DIVE MOVE ON TO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
SECRETARY IF YOU CAN PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
CONSENT CALENDAR AB THREE EIGHTY
FRAZIER TO PASS EVERY YEAR FOR
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS.
AB EIGHT SIX NINE CUNNINGHAM DO
PASS [inaudible]
PETRIE-NORRIS. THREE NORRIS I
PATTERSON.
BURKE BURKE I LACKEY.
LACKEY I MEDINA MEDINA AYE QUIRK
SILVA SMITH.
SMITH BY.
GREAT MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM NOT
NUMBER.
SEVEN MR CHILD A. B..
NINE SEVENTY SIX THE MORNING
GOOD MORNING THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMUNITY [inaudible]
OUR ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE OR A
AYE HAS AN INCREDIBLE ABILITY TO
CREATE A GLOBAL PARADIGM SHIFT
TO THAT MAY PROPEL OUR SOCIETY
INTO.
AN AUTOMATION H. IN ALSO
PROPOSED UNIQUE SOLUTIONS TO
SOME OF THE WORLD'S GREATEST
PROBLEMS SO ITS APPLICATION MAY
SOON BECOME IMMERSED IN EVERY
MAJOR AREA OF OUT.
OF WORK AND ALSO PERSONALIZE SO
SUCH AS TRANSPORTATION
COMMUNICATIONS ON FINANCE HEALTH
CARE EDUCATION COMMITTEE JUSTICE
AND PAYMENT.
JUST TO NAME A FEW WHILE THIS
EMERGING TECHNOLOGY PRESENTS
OPPORTUNITIES -- IT ALSO COMES
WITH ITS OWN CHALLENGES.
ARE POTENTIALLY INCLUDING
DISPLACING WORKERS LOSS OF
PRIVACY FOR EXAMPLE OR
REINFORCING INSTITUTIONAL BIASES
AMONG OTHER THINGS.
ARE THESE LEGAL AND ETHICAL
CHALLENGES WILL DEFINITELY
REQUIRE INVOLVEMENT FROM ALL
STAKEHOLDERS -- TO ADDRESS OUR
AND AS A RESULT ARE WE THE
LEGISLATORS SOME US FACILITATE
OUR DIALOGUE TO FIND A BALANCE
BETWEEN.
ACTING OUR STATE'S POPULATION
WHILE SIMULTANEOUSLY ARE DRIVING
INNOVATION AS WELL AS
PRODUCTIVITY AS A LEADER IN THE
GLOBAL MARKETPLACE THE BILL IS
INTENDED TO BEGIN THAT PROCESS.
ALL AND CONVERSATION BY
ESTABLISHING THE ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE I IN OUR GOVERNMENT
SERVICES -- COMMISSION --
BASICALLY TO GATHER INPUT ON HOW
IT ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE AND
DATA SCIENCE COULD BE USED TO
IMPROVE OUR STATE SERVICES.
SO WITH WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY
ASK HER AYE VOTE.
AT ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
SCENE NINE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
SCENE NINE QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
ALRIGHT WE HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE I RESPECTFULLY ASK HER
ABOUT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SECRETARY IF YOU CAN
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS PETRIE-NORRIS HI
PETRIE-NORRIS HI PATTERSON.
BURKE BURKE I LACKEY.
LACKEY I MEDINA MEDINA AYE QUIRK
SILVA.
SMITH SMITH I THE BILL IS OUT
AND LEAVE THE ROAD OPEN FOR
OTHERS TO ADD ON TO YOUR MUCH
EVERYONE
.
GOOD MORNING GOOD MORNING WE ARE
GONNA JUMP RIGHT IN I FILE ITEM
FIVE MISTER NAZARIAN.
AB.
SEVEN ONE SEVEN GOOD MORNING
MISS CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
AB SEVEN ONE SEVEN CREATES A
SAFER SYSTEM FOR COLLECTING
STATE TAX AND FEE PAYMENTS FROM
CASH BASED BUSINESSES.
INCLUDING CANNABIS THIS BILL
DIRECTS THE STATE TO CONTRACT
WITH AN ARMORED CAR SERVICE
PROVIDER TO SET UP AN OPT IN
PROGRAM FOR CANNABIS BUSINESSES
WISHING TO HAVE THEIR TECH CASH
TAX.
AND FEE PAYMENTS PICKED UP
COUNTED AND TRANSPORTED TO A
BANK OR FINANCIAL INSTITUTION.
THERE ABOUT ELEVEN STATES THAT
HAVE LEGALIZED RECREATIONAL
MARIJUANA WITH MEDICAL MARIJUANA
LEGAL IN TWENTY TWO STATES
UNFORTUNATELY SINCE MARIJUANA IS
STILL.
ILLEGAL UNDER FEDERAL LAW
CANNABIS BUSINESSES ARE LARGELY
UNABLE TO ACCESS BASIC BANKING
SERVICES.
THE INABILITY TO WRITE CHECKS
MAKE AND RECEIVE ELECTRONIC
PAYMENTS OR ACCEPT CREDIT CARD.
OF OF DEATH AND DEBIT CARD CARDS
MEANS THE INDUSTRY DEALS WITH
LARGE SUMS OF CASH THE SECURITY
RISK EXTENDS BEYOND THE INDUSTRY
AFFECTING STATE AGENCIES.
COLLECTING CASH TAX PAYMENTS AND
ULTIMATELY.
OUR COMMUNITIES GIVEN THE STATE
LEVEL MOMENTUM ON THIS ISSUE WE
HOPE IT IS ONLY A MATTER OF TIME
UNTIL THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
TAKES ACTION TO ENABLE CANNABIS
BUSINESSES.
ACCESS TO BANKING UNTIL THEN
THIS BILL CREATES A STOPGAP
METHOD FOR CURTAILING SOME OF
THE SAFETY ISSUES.
ASSOCIATED WITH PAYING TAXES
USING MOUNTAINS OF CASH -- I'M
JOINED BY HAYDEN TRIP PACK ON
BEHALF OF GUARD -- WORLD AND TIM
CROMARTIE ON BEHALF OF HDL WHO I
DON'T KNOW IF TIM HAS MADE IT IN
YET.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR THANK
YOU FOR HAVING ME I HATE IN
TRAFFIC GUARD WORLD WE ARE A
LARGE ARMORED CAR CASH
TRANSPORTATION COMPANY.
ACROSS THE STATE -- AND ACROSS
THE COUNTRY.
TODAY WE WORK WITH.
AGENCIES MUNICIPALITIES CITIES
ACROSS THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
TO ASSIST THEM IN THIS ISSUE --
THERE IS A SECURITY REST THAT'S
IN PLACE TODAY -- BECAUSE WHAT'S
HAPPENING IS -- TAXPAYERS THAT
THAT ARE AUTHORIZED REQUIRED --
TO LEGALLY PAY THEIR TAXES ARE
HAVING TO LITTLE WE TAKE BAGS OF
CASH INTO CITY HALL -- IT TO
CERTAIN BUILDINGS ACROSS THE
STATE -- WHAT WE'VE DONE IS
IMPLEMENTED A PROGRAM WHERE WE
WOULD GO TO THE TAXPAYERS
LOCATION?
UP PICK UP THE CASH DEPOSIT ON
BEHALF OF THE STATE BRING IT
BACK TO ONE OF OUR A SECURE
PROCESSING CENTERS WHERE WE
WOULD PROCESS OF DEPOSIT JUST
LIKE.
BANK OF AMERICA WELLS FARGO OR
ANY OF THE LARGE FINANCIAL
INSTITUTIONS AND WE WOULD
PROCESS IT INTO THIS -- THE
INSTITUTIONS -- FINANCIAL
ACCOUNTS SO -- ON BEHALF OF THE
AGENCY OR THE CITY THE STATE.
THEY WOULD RECEIVE THE DEPOSIT.
IN THEIR IN THEIR ACCOUNT
WITHOUT EVER HAVING TO TOUCH THE
CASH OR HANDLE IT IN ANY WAY.
EVER HAVING TO SEE THE TAXPAYER
REALLY THEY WOULD JUST RECEIVE
THAT DEPOSIT INTO THEIR ACCOUNT --
TODAY WERE DOING THIS VERY
SUCCESSFULLY AND LOOK TO EXPAND
IT.
THE ONE ISSUE THAT WE'RE RUNNING
INTO IS THAT THE THERE'S NOT TO
ANY AUTHORIZATION FOR THEM TO
PAY FOR THE SERVICE OR HAVE THE
TAXPAYER PAY FOR THE SERVICE.
SO THIS WOULD REALLY ASSIST IN
THAT PROCESS -- KEEPING EVERYONE
SAFE AND SECURE AND MAKING IT A
LOT MORE EFFICIENT ACROSS THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU I ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
ANY FRANK ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CANNABIS INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION THIS IS A COMMON
SENSE BELT BILL TO HELP KEEP OUR
EMPLOYEES SAFE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU ANY WITNESS SAYS AN
OPPOSITION.
SEE NINE QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SINCE THE THIS.
THE BANKS CANNOT ACCEPT OF MONEY
CASH -- FROM CANNABIS -- WHEN
WHEN IT WHEN WHEN THE ARMORED A?
VEHICLESBRING THE CASH TO THE
STATE WHERE WHERE WOULD THAT BE.
IN A NOT.
PHYSICALLY BUT WHAT AGENCIES
WOULD ACCEPT THE MONEY WHERE
WOULD THEY YOU SAID THAT YOU
WOULD YOU WOULD BE DOING THE I
TO THE AGENCIES NEVER REALLY GET
THE CASH THEY JUST GET THE
DEPOSIT INTO.
OUT OF JUMPING ON BECAUSE GUARD
IS A NATIONAL COMPANY AND
HANDLES A WORK FOR MANY OTHER
PRIVATE AND PUBLIC ENTITIES.
HE MAY HAVE GIVEN AN EXAMPLE --
TO ABOUT THAT HE MAY HAVE GIVEN
AN EXAMPLE ABOUT IN MAKING AN
INVESTMENT IN A BANK BUT IN THIS
CASE IN CALIFORNIA IT WOULD ONLY
BE -- THE THE STATE AGENCIES
THAT WOULD BE RECEIVING.
THE FUNDING NOW IF FOR THE STATE
AGENCY WANTS THAT CASH TO ALSO
BE DEPOSITED.
INTO ITS ACCOUNT [inaudible]
THEN.
THAT WOULD BE SOMETHING THAT
WOULD BE NEGOTIATED IN ADVANCE.
WITH WITH THE COURIER SERVICE
AND WOULD BE IMPLEMENTED -- BUT
BUT BECAUSE OF THE ISSUE OF
BANKING -- CHANCE AND THE THE
MOST THE IMPORTANT PART OF WHAT
I WAS FOCUSED ON THE BILL -- WAS
TO ENSURE THAT THE
TRANSPORTATION.
HAVE HAPPENS IN A SAFE MANNER SO
THAT THE CASH BEING TRANSPORTED
FROM THE BUSINESS BECAUSE IN
CERTAIN CASES -- THE BUSINESS
MIGHT BE TWO THREE HOURS AWAY
FROM WHERE THE BAD FORM WHERE
THE STATE AGENCY IS THAT'S
ACCEPTING THE CASH.
THAT MAKES OF ALL THAT IS MY
QUESTION THE STATE AGENCY THAT
WOULD RECEIVE THE CASH WOULD
JUST BE THE THE TAX BOARD
[inaudible]
FRANCHISE BOARD.
DEPENDS WHO IT'S GOING.
TO DEPENDS WHO IT'S GOING TO IT
THERE WAS A I THINK THE BE -- WE
HAD A SMALL PIECE AT SOME POINT --
BUT NOW THAT ROLE HAS GONE TO
SEE THE TFA -- FRANCHISE TAX
BOARD MIGHT HAVE A RULES SO.
DEPENDS ON THE STATE AGENCIES
THAT ARE RECEIVING IT.
AND THEY WOULD TAKE THE CASH
DIRECTLY TO THOSE AGENCY YEARS
OR THAT KIND OF THE IN BETWEEN.
TO EXPAND A LITTLE WELL SO SAID
THE CAREER IS THE IN BETWEEN.
BECAUSE WILL NOW WHAT HAPPENS IS
OF OF CANNABIS BUSINESS BUT
PROPRIETORS ARE ACTUALLY TAKING
DUFFEL BAGS OF CASH.
INTO A STATE OFFICE.
WHICH MAKES THAT OFFICE VERY
VULNERABLE.
AND THE GOAL IS TO TAKE THAT
VULNERABILITY AWAY BY.
HAVING AN INTERMEDIARY.
THAT WOULD ACTUALLY PICK UP THE
CASH PROCESS IT.
AND THEN.
EITHER MAKE THE ACTUAL DEPOSIT
OR SAFELY GET THE CASH TO THE
STATE AGENCY.
IT IN IN A DISCREET MANNER SO
THAT IT DOESN'T CREATE.
IT DOESN'T.
GET ATTENTION OBVIOUSLY
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING THEM WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE.
SURE AYE AYE IF MADAM CHAIR
INDULGES SINCE THE WE WE HAVE A
TEN JOINING US WOULD YOU LIKE TO
SAY A QUICK WORD WARRINGTON
THANK YOU I APOLOGIZE MARTIN'S
THANK YOU SO WHATEVER -- WE ARE
SUPPORT OF THE BILL BUT I I WANT
TO EMPHASIZE THAT I IN MY FORMAL
AS A LOBBYIST FOR THE LEAGUE
CALIFORNIA CITIES WE HELPED
CRAFT.
THE TODAY'S REGULATORY STRUCTURE
IN THE ONE MAJOR THING THAT IS
MISSING.
IS A SYSTEMATIC COMPONENT FOR
HOW TO DISPOSE OF THE VAST
VOLUMES OF CASH.
THAT IS A PROBLEM FOR BUSINESSES
AND GOVERNMENT ENTITIES A LIKE A
GOOD GOVERNMENT ENTITIES AT BOTH
THE STATE AND LOCAL LEVEL SO
THIS IS ADDRESSING A BADLY
NEEDED -- PIECE OF THE
REGULATORY STRUCTURE AND I
CURRENTLY WORK.
AS A CANNABIS CONSULTANT WITH A
STEEL COMPANIES WE HAVE AT LEAST
A HUNDRED AND TWENTY FIVE CITIES
OF CLIENTS THE WHOLE STRUGGLE
WITH THIS ISSUE.
THERE NEEDS TO BE SYSTEMATIC
MECHANISM OF FOR THE DISPOSAL OF
THE CASH THAT IS SAFE AND SECURE
THIS BILL WILL ADDRESS THAT.
THANK YOU WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A
VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND THE RECOMMENDATION
AND IS TO PASS TO REVENUE TAX
WHICH WAS CALDERON.
HOW DO WE HAVE A MOTION WE HAVE
A MOTION AND SECOND THANK YOU?
THANK YOU.
HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
[inaudible]
PETRIE-NORRIS.
BURKE.
BURKE HI PATTERSON PATTERSON I
LACKEY LACKEY I MEDINA.
MEDINA I QUIRK SILVA.
SMITH SMITH I THANK YOU.
THE THE MEASURES OUT THE LEVEL
THE ROLE OPEN THANK YOU FOR THE
CHAIR.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FONG WOULD YOU
LIKE TO OPEN -- WE'LL START WITH
FILE ITEM AB.
SIXTY THREE I THANK YOU CHAIR
MEMBERS IS MY PLEASURE TO
PRESENT AB SIXTY THREE A BILL
THAT WILL ALLOW THE PUBLIC TO
COMMENT.
AND RATE THEIR PERSONAL
EXPERIENCES WITH STATE AGENCIES
THERE IS CURRENTLY NO PUBLIC
MECHANISM TO PROVIDE FEEDBACK ON
STATE AGENCIES.
SOME AGENCIES HAVE A FEEDBACK
FORM THAT ONLY THE STATE AGENCY
CAN VIEW.
THIS BILL CREATES A YELP LIKE
PLATFORM FOR FOR CONSTITUENTS TO
RATE THEIR INTERACTIONS WITH
CALIFORNIA STATE AGENCIES.
AND PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENTS ON
THE SERVICE THAT THEY RECEIVED.
AFTER INTERACTION WITH THIS
AGENCY CONSTITUENTS CAN PROVIDE
FEEDBACK BY THE EXPERIENCE AND
RATE HOW WELL THEY ARE SERVED ON
A SCALE OF A TO F. --
APPLICATIONS LIKE YELP ALLOW
CUSTOMERS TO RATE AND GIVE
FEEDBACK ON A VARIETY OF
SERVICES.
AND THE TRANSPARENCY OF THESE
PUBLIC POSTINGS AND RATINGS
INCENTIVIZE BETTER CUSTOMER
SERVICE AND MORE RESPONSIVENESS
TO CUSTOMER COMPLAINTS AND
CONCERNS.
THIS BILL ALLOWS THE PUBLIC TO
SEE WHAT KIND OF EXPERIENCES
OTHER PEOPLE HAVE WITH THEIR
GOVERNMENT BY DOING THIS
CONSTITUENTS CONCEDE THAT THEY
ARE BEING HEARD AND STATE
AGENCIES CAN SEE AREAS THEY
EXCEL IN.
IN AREAS THAT NEED IMPROVEMENT.
WE EXPECT SERVICE AND
ACCOUNTABILITY TO IMPROVE THAT
OUR STATE AGENCIES WE NEED A
MECHANISM TO ENSURE THE PUBLIC
CAN KEEP KEEP THEM ACCOUNTABLE.
CALIFORNIA'S GOVERNMENT SHOULD
STRIVE BETTER TO UNDERSTAND THE
NEEDS OF OUR CONSTITUENTS
IMPROVING SERVICES AND PROGRAMS
ADMINISTERED BY THE STATE WITH
TAX DOLLARS.
I EXPECT THAT'S WHAT I ABOUT.
THANK YOU WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEN ON COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE [inaudible]
SINCE.
ABOUT HIM HIS GAVEL TO YOU SEE
YOU DO WHATEVER YOU WANT.
DO I HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
UGH WE LIKE TO CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS A REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
BURKE HI BURKE HI PATTERSON
PATTERSON HI PETRIE-NORRIS
[inaudible]
PETRIE-NORRIS I LACKEY LACKEY
AYE MEDINA MEDINA AYE QUIRK
SILVA.
SMITH.
SMITH ON THANK YOU SO I THAT
BILL IS OUT WILL BE THE ROLE OF
AND TELL OUR MEMBERS TO ADD ON
AND I BELIEVE YOU HAVE ANOTHER
BOB YES.
I THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
AB TWO EIGHT NINE CREATES AN
INDEPENDENT CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
RECORDS ACT A REFEREE IN THE
FORM OF A BUT SPENT.
DETERMINE IF A P. R. A REQUEST
WAS WRONGFULLY DENIED.
THE CURRENT PROCESS TO APPROVING
OR DENYING A CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
RECORDS ACT REQUEST PROVIDES A
LITTLE TO NO TRANSPARENCY.
IN OUR CURRENT PROCESS STATE
AGENCIES CAN DENY A CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC ACCESS PUBLIC RECORDS ACT
REQUEST KNOWING THAT THERE IS NO
APPEALS OPTION OTHER THAN TO
TAKE THE AGENCY TO COURT.
I AGENCIES HAVE AND CAN SIDE
EXEMPTIONS IN THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC RECORDS ACT THAT HAVE NO
RELATION TO THE RELATE REQUEST
IN QUESTION AS A RIP BASIS FOR
DENYING A REQUEST.
WHEN A P. R. I REQUEST IS DENIED
THE PUBLIC HAS NO RECOURSE OTHER
THAN TO FILE AN EXPENSIVE
LAWSUIT?
WHICH IS OFTEN NOT FEASIBLE FOR
ORDINARY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC.
IN IT IS A TRANSPARENCY
ACCOUNTABILITY WHICH WAS THE
INTENT OF THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
RECORDS ACT WE NEED A STRUCTURE
AND PROCESS TO PREVENT STATE
AGENCIES FROM WORKING AROUND THE
SYSTEM.
THIS BILL ADDRESSES THESE
EFFICIENCIES BY ESTABLISHING AN
INDEPENDENT REFEREE WHO AT THE
REQUEST OF THE INDIVIDUAL OR
GROUP OR MEDIA OUTLET WHO
SUBMITTED THE REQUEST CAN REVIEW
THE DENIED PUBLIC RECORDS ACT
REQUEST AND SERVE AS A OMBUDSMAN.
AND AN ARBITER OR WHETHER THE
STATE AGENCY HAS LEGITIMATE
GROUNDS FOR DENYING THE REQUEST.
THE ISSUE IS PARTICULARLY
IMPORTANT IN LIGHT OF THE MAJOR
PROBLEMS WE'VE SEEN AT THE DMV.
IN ORDER TO GET PUBLIC DOCUMENTS
RELATED TO ITS OPERATIONS ONE
MAJOR NEWS PUBLICATION HAD TO
THREATEN A LAWSUIT.
THIS IS NOT THE WAY THINGS
SHOULD OPERATE WE NEED MORE
TRANSPARENCY AND FAIRNESS A
PUBLIC RECORDS ACT STRUCTURE
THAT.
THAT ENSURES THAT WE HAVE REAL
ACCOUNTABILITY.
THIS BILL SUPPORTED BY NUMBER OF
NEWS OUTLETS INCLUDING THE SAN
DIEGO UNION TRIBUNE HAS ALSO
SUPPORTED BY THE BIXEL CHAMBER
OF COMMERCE IN THE KERN COUNTY
TAXPAYERS ASSOCIATION.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK.
FOR THANK YOU WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE WOULD BE PROUD
OF CALIFORNIA NEWS PUBLISHERS
ASSOCIATION WE HAVE TAKEN A
SUPPORT OF AMENDED POSITION ON
THIS BILL.
THERE TO AMENDMENTS THAT WE
THINK WOULD MAKE THIS BILL MOST
EFFECTIVE FOR THE INDIVIDUALS
IT'S INTENDED TO HELP THE MOST.
THAT WOULD BE TO EXPAND IT TO
INCLUDE.
A REQUEST THAT ARE DENIED BY
LOCAL AGENCIES THE VAST MAJORITY
OF CALLS I GET ON A DAILY BASIS
ARE FROM.
REQUESTED HAVE BEEN DENIED BY
LOCAL AGENCIES AND THE SECOND
WOULD BE THAT A VOLUME OF
OPINIONS BY THIS OMBUDSMAN OR
PUT OUT.
THAT -- BOTH AGENCIES AND
INDIVIDUALS CAN THEN USE IN THE
FUTURE TO HOPEFULLY.
DECREASE THE NUMBER OF DISPUTES
WE HAVE SO WE THINK THE AUTHOR
FOR BRINGING FOR THE BILL.
VERY SUPPORTIVE OF THE CONCEPT
WE THINK THOSE TWO AMENDMENTS
WOULD REALLY MAKE IT A VERY
STRONG BILL THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
WITNESSES AN OPPOSITION.
SAY NINE QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
GREAT RESPECT THAT'S EVER ABOUT
RIGHT THANK YOU I SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY PETRIE-NORRIS HI
PETRIE-NORRIS I PATTERSON
PATTERSON I BURKE.
BURKE HI LACKEY LACKEY AYE
MEDINA MEDINA I COOK SILVA.
SMITH SMITH HI.
GREAT THANK YOU OUT TO THE
FEDERAL OPEN TO ALLOW ME TO
MEMBERS TO ADD ON BOB.
THAT IS THE END AS OUR AGENDA
FOR TODAY.
OB BUT SECRETARY IF YOU CAN
PLEASE READ THROUGH THE ROLES
FOR THE BILLS AND WE CAN OUT
AUTHORS THAT HAVE BEEN MISSING
I'M SORRY ADD THAT WOULD HAVE
BEEN MISSING.
THE CONSENT CALENDAR A. B. THREE
EIGHTY AND A. B..
EIGHT SIXTY NINE PATTERSON
PATTERSON I AB SIX FIFTY THREE
PATTERSON PATTERSON I AB SEPT
ONCE SEVEN ONE SEVEN PATTERSON
PATTERSON I I'M SORRY YOUR ADDED
TO THAT ONE AT PETRIE-NORRIS
[inaudible]
PETRIE-NORRIS I AB AND NINE
SEVEN SIX PATTERSON PATTERSON I
AB FOURTEEN THIRTY PATTERSON.
PATTERSON I OUT WE WILL LEAVE I
WILL WE'LL STAY FOR FIVE
ADDITIONAL MINUTES IF MISS QUIRK
SILVA.
WITH LIKE TO COM AND OUT ON TO
WILL BILLS WILL BE HERE TILL
.
NINE FIFTY ALRIGHT FIRST AFTER
%
I'M GONNA CALL THE TICKET IN
[inaudible]
THAT.
ONE IT'S SECTOR IF YOU CAN GO
AHEAD AND I CALL THE BOSS.
THE CONSENT CALENDAR A. B. THE
RE EIGHTY EIGHT N. A. B..
EIGHT SIX NINE QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA HI.
AB SIXTY THREE QUIRK SILVA.
AB TWO EIGHTY NINE QUIRK SILVA
QUIRK SILVA HI.
AB EIGHT SIX FIVE THREE QUIRK
SILVA QUIRK SILVA.
FIVE AB SEVEN ONE SEVEN QUIRK
SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA I AB NINE SEVEN SIX
QUIRK SILVA QUIRK SILVA AYE.
AB FOURTEEN THIRTY QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA I THAT WAS IT THANK
YOU I WE ARE THAT IS SOME
ACCOUNTABILITY AND
ADMINISTRATIVE REVIEW COMMITTEE
HAS NOW TURNED